President Trump is avoiding discussion
of Kim jong-un's human rights record and
praising the North Korean dictator's
negotiating skills in a Fox News
interview the president dismissed
questions about his talks with Kim and
commended him for being a tough guy and
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo told
reporters in South Korea that questions
about verifying North Korea's removal of
nuclear weapons were quote insulting and
ridiculous and frankly ludicrous
Ouisa Jang is at the White House we did
good morning good morning John a
president Trump picked secretary Pompeo
to lead the negotiations with North
Korea which are expected to start up
again in a week but the grueling task of
hammering out details and a lack of
specifics has drawn fierce criticism
while the White House says the two sides
have already settled on some terms that
are not yet in writing with the
president back at the White House
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo remains
in Asia we're gonna get complete
denuclearization only then will there be
relief from the sanctions briefing
American allies on the outcome of the
Singapore summit the United States the
Republic of Korea and Japan remain
committed to achieving the complete
verifiable and irreversible
denuclearization of North Korea Pompeius
remarks differed from the joint
statement between the president and kim
jeong-hoon
which did not include the language
verifiable and irreversible nor did it
mention North Korea's human rights
records he's still some done some really
bad things
yeah but so have a lot of other people
done some really bad things in an
interview with Fox News president Trump
defended his new foe turned friend know
he is a killer
execute hey when you take over a country
country people and you take it over from
your father if you could do that at 27
years old
you I mean that's one in 10,000 that
could do that and also expressed
confidence that verification would be
part of the process
I believe that chairman Kim wants to get
it done okay but the president faced
criticism for declaring there is no
longer a nuclear threat from North Korea
what planet is the President on saying
it doesn't make it so North Korea still
has nuclear weapons Pompeyo believes the
north will take steps toward major
disarmament by the end of President
Trump's first term the Secretary of
State says teams of experts and
scientists will be prepared to start
dismantling weapons soon after a deal is
struck but what remains to be seen is
whether those inspectors will include an
international coalition or be
american-led Gayle all right we should
change still a lot of questions thank
you so much